geico's name is not a small name they're
everywhere branding they're commercial
they're gecko they've made some of the
funniest commercials what are you doing
leaving the state of california you're
in the insurance business why do you
think this is happening
i have zero clue a guy goes down to do
this all i know is that a lot of
companies are cutting staff these days
we've seen that robin hood just cut a
bunch of staff facebook mark zuckerberg
has come out and said his staff
there's something going on in uh in
california that's for sure is that where
you're going with this yeah listen
the question this is this is what's
unique about this article it didn't say
geico is shutting down 78 offices
nationwide
okay
it says they're shutting down all
of their offices in one
specific state why
why why are you only
closing all of your offices it didn't
even say they're closing 38 of their 92
offices in the state of california it's
saying they're closing
all 38 of it office offices in
california is the climate bad in
california
are you choosing to leave is the
regulation just not worth it are the
taxes just not worth it is the cost per
lead you're getting that you have to pay
the commission for the agents to make
money for the lease you're paying for
the building to get the customer support
to be there and then have to go through
the loopholes that the state of
california offers just not worth it i
don't know but this story that title
right there says a lot geico has closed
all 38 of its locations in california
does not say any other state and doesn't
say a percentage of their offices it
says all that makes you think tom what
do you think i think it's a business
environment in california because geico
is not leaving
geico is continuing to service and to
sell to consumers in the seventh largest
economy in the world california so
they're not leaving
they're not leaving they're just saying
it is hard to do business here in
california what and you know what i
think it could be a combination of or
all the reasons pat just said and
they're like you know what we're out of
here but also i take a look through the
between the lines really quickly
hundreds of employees will no longer
sell insurance through telephone agents
in the state could it be that finding
that that being able to pay people to be
a telephone agent in california does not
match with the cost of living in
california maybe they can't find enough
of these agents i don't know but what
this says to me hey we're still going to
sell this online but we're not going to
have um you know offices in california i
think it means the california business
climate was
was difficult they still want the
business from the seventh largest
economy with the greatest automobile
culture in america
they don't want that market of course
they want that market yeah i think where
you're basically saying this is a
metaphor for why you left california
you're in the insurance business here is
this i mean i'm reading between the tea
leaves here actually there was a reason
you left california a lot of people
between the lines and reading the tea
leaves yeah both of those things between
between the lines and the smoke and some
tea leaves the um
speaking there must be a there must be
exactly there must be a reason no we
didn't do this taxes regulation is
ultimately why you left california but
what i'm trying to say to you is we
didn't leave california so
if if i
the the
you're saying that california left you
no no he's saying we are permanently
shut down and can't
write new policies
in california an agent told the reporter
on thursday so an agent who worked for
geico that's 38 offices i don't know how
many hundreds of agents but an agent
said i can't no longer sell geico in the
state of california that's like php
saying hey to all the people that are in
california you can no longer sell in
california why would a company this size
shut down a state that's the sixth or
seventh largest economy in the world
that's right why would you do it that's
what i'm interested in knowing because
there there is a uh
you know like the uh she no came out
shakira's getting a divorce her and her
husband getting the divorce remember
that and then a month later the story
comes out and says what taxes
eight years going to jail for uh taxes
okay so you're like oh
what happened there okay you know
because if you're married you got tax
issues who's linked to the tax issues if
you're married both of you if you're
divorced is it you so you don't know
maybe we're not gonna know why geico
left california
all i'm saying is
why is a company as big and pro you know
who owns geico you know who's the
biggest shareholder in geico it's bob
so you think buffett
you know like i don't know i i just
think there's got to be something going
on there with the climate that's getting
somebody like this to say we're leaving
the sixth largest economy and we've got
to get you to think about that pat
that's a great point and who runs to the
microphone the california state
department of insurance
and uh
it
says hang on everything's okay we
encourage consumers to look at their
options for coverage in california's
competitive marketplace that's kind of
the way that quote that's the frog
that's a freaked out bureaucrat saying
everything's cool california we got all
these insurance companies no problem
you've got a lot of choices you know
they're out there running out there
saying everything's cool why is the
state running out to say all is well
when a company moves the answer is
i think it was the regulatory
environment that's my guess what what's
so interesting about all these
conversations is they're they're all
really about competition
right it's it's it's competition because
this is the same this is what's
happening playing out right now in the
usa especially over the past three years
is just competition right people
migrating and moving to where makes
sense california is losing people
florida is gaining people and so on and
so forth and so
to me it's interesting you know i feel i
feel bad for
the people who end up kind of
just casualty like this
how many people just lost their jobs
from this right like that that sucks
um but i do think in the long term with
all of this stuff it's going to be
really interesting to see
where it all goes i think we're at such
a transition point
right now in our countries in so many
ways
and it's scary and it's unnerving and
it's freaking a lot of people out
in many ways for many different reasons
but i think that in the long term it's
going to be
it's going to be interesting just to see
where it lands and see where see where
stuff is in 10 years from now it would
be really interesting it's going to be
we'll see what's going on but all i know
is you know this is a little bit uh
strange when somebody as big as geico as
profitable as geico
leaves the biggest economy in america
what are you doing leaving that place
it's a very strange move to
leave you got so many potential
customers that can no longer be written
by agents this is a very very weird move
and it's terrible for the department of
insurance so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]